hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation application of brain model
technology presented by dr. Alison nutri
desert and department of pediatrics
cellular molecular medicine and director
of the stem cell program at the
University of California San Diego my
name is Robert Horton of thermo Fisher
Scientific and I will be your moderator
for today's presentation before I begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting any questions
you may have at any time during this
presentation do so just click on the ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and type your question
into the Dropbox that appears on screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time to at the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please use the
ask a question box to let us know of any
technical difficulties with that please
allow me to introduce today's speaker
dr. Alex DeMetrick earning doctorate in
genetics from University of San Paulo in
Brazil in 2001 he then moved to the Salk
Institute as a few Latin American fellow
in 2002 for his postdoctoral training in
the field the neurosciences stem cell
biology shortly thereafter dr. matru
joined the school medicine at the
University of California San Diego where
he currently resides today the research
primarily focuses on modeling
neurological diseases such as autism
spectrum disorders using human induced
pluripotent stem cells his lab has
developed several techniques to culture
human neurons and glia from basic
research to drug discovery platforms his
received numerous awards including the
prestigious I NIH directors new
innovator award their Emerald Foundation
young investor award the rock star of
innovation from Connect NIH Arika Award
among many others with that I will now
turn it over to dr. Alex meetry
all right thank you Robert and think oh
thermal for making this happen so this
is a nice set of speakers I heard good
things about previous speakers so I'll
try to to keep it up the pace and as
Robert mentioned my lab focus on the
applications of brain model technology
in what we mean is the ability to
generate neural cells from induced
pluripotent stem cells or or human
prepotent
embryonic stem cells so one of the key
things in my lab is that we focus on
neurodevelopmental disorders in and we
use those stem cells as a model system
one of the biggest limitations that we
have in modeling neurological
neurodevelopmental disorders such as
autism or even late onset diseases that
have an Umbreon ik origin it is really
the access to the embryonic human brain
so it's not ethical to using vasive
methodologies to study the healthy human
brain in uterus
nobody would volunteer for that but we
rely on technologies such as ultrasound
technology things that don't have the
high level definition to really
understand what happens at the level of
single cells or or even synapses so
because of that we turn into these brain
organoid models so we can recapitulate
these very early stages of human neural
development in the lab in controlled
situations and before I start I wanna
mention that there are limitations as
well and I it's nice to be upfront about
among those limitations so the media
often call those mini brains in a dish
and I think the public perception is
that we actually have a small human
brain growing in the lab and that's
that's the wrong perception so this
bring organoids they have severe
limitations for example they are highly
mature neurons they are not vascularized
not all cell types are represented for
example microglia who has a different
thing Briony oranges have to be a
splinted back in some of the protocols
even the ideal culture condition has
been empirically defined so there is no
optimization of the median factors and
finally I think one of the biggest
questions about this model as well as
any other in vitro model is the
translate ability or the capacity to
learn something from the human brain by
just studying those neurons in a dish so
with all these limitations we ask in
this technology be disruptive or or is
just incremental from what we previously
had on on the 2d monolayer cultures with
these ideas so over the years my lab has
been developing a novel protocol to
create brain organoids and these are
patent-pending bring organoids so you
can guide them to different brain
regions using small molecules or factors
so most of the talk today is going to be
about the cortex and our protocol starts
really with single-cell level so we
dissociate IPS C's or even in bruenig
stem cells and we keep them in single
cell suspension for about two days only
after that we induce in a very short
cause of induction to the different
brain regions that you want a target in
the case of cortex we used with many
abyssion but we don't leave these
factors over there just like a short
post after that we induce these neural
progenitor cells to proliferate in
really a quieter cell mass so you can
follow the next step our neuronal
differentiation where this cell is
spontaneously will differentiating the
different subtype of neurons and other
cells that you expect doing brain
development and again I mean we are not
inducing them with receptors you're just
relying on the natural programming
genetic programming of these cells and
they do that in a very reliable way so
and then you enter the neuronal
motivation phase and this could last
month I mean we can keep this organized
alive inside a lab for several years
actually so it's quite a robust
we do see some apoptosis or necrosis in
the center of this organoids
after a couple of months but it's much
much later compared to previous
protocols and when we make a slice of
one of these organized now we have some
kind of structure so this is a
representation of a four month old
organoid so you can clearly see that
there is a ventricular zone and this is
where most of the progenitor cells
reside and they will differentiate into
microglia cells that will send processes
to the outer layers where neural
progenitor cells and glia presenter
cells will take advantage of those
cables to migrate out to the periphery
and start building what we call it the
cortical plate as those neural mature we
can start seeing the different subtypes
of of neurons appearing and just to give
you like a snapshot of what are the cell
populations that we can get after four
month we have run single cell RNA seek
and this is just one of the
representations of these Macs
as you can see in blue most of the cells
are glutamatergic neurons by foreman you
start to see that those blue cells they
start to divide between two populations
one is going to be upper cortical
neurons the other one's going to be more
towards the lower cortical neurons there
is a population of present ourselves
here in purple that will continue to
produce neurons and later on glial cells
at this stage the percentage of glial
cells is between five and ten percent it
will grow up or show you in a minute
and very interestingly we also have a
population of GABAergic negatory neurons
that appear is spontaneously from this
protocol so in a single unit you can
have both with glutamatergic and
GABAergic neurons so you can use these
kind of networks to test balances
between excitations in inhibitions so
one can visualize in cortical markers
using staining moody staining
I'm showing here the pattern of
migration from the center of the present
ourselves between two close owns over to
the cortical layer you can see this
stage you already have like some TDR to
transient cells as well as CTP to
positive cells in here and I have two
graphics here on the right I just want
to highlight two important things one is
the ratio between astrocytes and neurons
so this is percentage of cells over the
course of eight month and at very early
stages one month most of the cells that
we have our neurons represented by the
map tube positive cells in the black
bars and this population grows a little
bit and then we start to decrease by the
time is decreasing the percentage of
astrocytes
represented in the white bar but the
jsap positive cells they start to
increase and I just noted between six
and eight months and they kind of took
over the entire organ organ in it
becomes a one-to-one ratio between
neurons and astrocytes this is really
what would expect for early stages of
human neural development so in the other
graph we have different subtype of
cortical neurons and we are representing
here in 62 and sat b2 and again over the
course of eight months what we see is
that this population start to stratify
the beginning most of the cells are CTP
to positive cells but as we reach for
six months of age the number of fat B to
positive cells start to become similar
so again I mean this is a very nice
protocol because it's dynamic is
different from your regular 2d culture
we have where you have most of the time
saying subtype of neurons and then we
ask I mean can we quantify or can we
match these organoids to normal human
development and this is a tricky
question because as I told you we don't
have a small brain we do have pieces of
cortex that are developing so the
comparison between organoids in the
brain is not straightforward and in
theory one could not even compare but we
do it anyways and one way to do that it
is by gene expression global gene
expression so we take advantage of
tissue banks like the brain span where
we upload our global gene expression
coming from my classes or different
stages of organoids then we use other
tools such as the contest to really help
us to make the match and what we can see
is that the early stages the IPS is
really matches within Bionic stem cells
but as one month organoids already moved
from that in chronic stages in are more
similar to early Nido fetal stages in a
three month organoid is already matching
the global gene expression that is
similar to late fetal stages or even a
post natal stage so if you just look at
the gene expression you might ask how
come like a three months organoid is
already matching like a late fetal stage
and there are two explanations possible
at least one is that the rapid organoids
are accelerated compared to normal human
development that's one explanation the
explanation is the post-mortem tissues
are really not recalculating exactly
what happens because there are RNA
degradation we don't know exactly the
age of these post-mortem tissues so
there is lots of unknowns my nonetheless
I mean it's Anna
it's nice to see that there's a
progression towards more mature neurons
over time so when my lab in other labs
start to see that we can recreate or
recapitulate some of these early stages
of brain development we look for
diseases to model and I think one of the
early diseases that we decided to model
was microcephaly and I think the most
striking example it is the type of
microcephaly that's caused by the Zika
virus and we took advantage of this
model and expose the brain organoid to
the Zika virus
and that was a very important tool to
prove causality between the circulating
Zika virus in Brazil and the severe
neurological defects and structural
defects that we see in the brains of the
foetus that were infected so this is a
published work so not to give too much
details but just to say that the Zika
virus were able to successfully
penetrate into the ventricles of this
organoid in kill transient preventer
cells and as a consequence what we have
the decrease in the number of certain
subtype of neurons such as CT p2
positive neurons and envy reduce the
thickness of the cortical plate so that
was a very nice proof of principle that
how environmental factor could actually
alter the structure of the human brain
so but we can also take advantage of
this model to test drugs and this is one
example we have been using these bring
organoids models and to test drugs this
is one positive data that we get with
the Zika virus in the figure here you
can see that a mock infected culture
produce viable brain organoids
putting the presence of a very low
amount of the Zika virus
if you waken long enough they would
usually kill all the cells and we were
able to find this drug called sofosbuvir
and these can protected the bring
organoids from the Zika virus because it
blocks the viral replication so that was
a very encouraging positive data using
these models who could repurpose this
drug for a possible new outbreak in one
of these countries but I told you in the
beginning that we work with a
neurodevelopmental disorders such as
autism and those diseases are hard to
find specific brain normalities on the
contrary what we have these stages or
these diseases are networks defect in
and we had no idea if this brain
organoids could actually
model neuronal networks so this is one
thing that my lab has been actively
focusing to to prove if this brain
organized would be a good model for that
purpose and to measure Network what we
did was to take advantage of Moochie
electrode arrays these are printed
electrodes in the bottom of wells where
you can plate your bring organoid just
on top of these electrodes and you can
record over time the beauty of these
technologies that it gives you network
activity over the course of several
weeks if not months and in it generates
a raster plot such as this one
represented on the top where you can see
that each channel this is just five of
the 64 channels that we have in here and
you can see that all the time when there
is a event or an activity we represent
by a tray so that spike event if you
have lots of spikes in a very short
period of time we call that a burst and
if you have lots of boards across
different channels we call that
synchrony and our data has to be
compared to something so this is what we
are plotting here is a mean firing rate
in Hertz which is an overall measure of
brain activity and we played it when we
plotted some of the work that was
previously done using IPS derive cells
or mouse primary cultures so I think you
can appreciate that most of the work
done so far it is below the 5 Hertz
threshold so how this compare to the
brain so a mouse brain would be around
18 Hertz and a primate brain would be
around 20 Hertz so the 2d system is
really not recap to lating that level of
activity that one would expect for a
more mature brain and even organoid or
previous protocols of organoid such as
these one year from quadrat at all from
the
all our other lab they can they were
able to keep the cells up to 32 weeks
and measure with which electrode arrays
but even though doesn't reach a level of
five Hort so to our surprise what we see
is that at 16 Hertz which our bring
organoids model ready see like a very
high level of activity compared to most
of the 2d monolayer cultures we had in
the past I'm plotting in this graphic an
average of eight organoid that was
measured weekly over the course of four
weeks and you can see that after about
six months we see this peak of activity
that we reach close to the twenty heart
and after 40 weeks each plateau we don't
see an increase in activity after 40
weeks but nonetheless the level of
activity that we can get it is already
comparable to to a more fully mature
brain which is amazing in as far as we
know very unprecedented tissue culture
and I can breakdown in numbers for you
so here in plotting different parameters
that we can capture with these electrode
arrays over the course of 10 months and
the number of spikes for example in the
first graphic would move from 3,000
spikes per minute to a little bit over
300,000 spikes per minute again this is
something that we were very surprised to
see that you can reach that level of
motivation in in-vitro the burst
frequency also increased the interval
between the births will decrease
suggesting that there is more
connectivity coming from as we mature
this organoid I also mentioned that we
have both excitatory inhibitory neurons
and we did some pharmacology on top of
this modulated arrays to lead to really
prove that we have both excitation
inhibition
for example when we treat this bring
organoids with by cooling who can
specifically block a GABAergic activity
we see an increase in
tivity or if we treat with baclofen
mussina or TTX these are drugs that will
block the glutamatergic synapses and you
abolished at the activity coming from
these organized so this is all very
exciting we can see a high level of
activity we can see addition excitation
in the same organ wide and if you have
everything in a single unit perhaps you
can start measuring other things such as
brain oscillations and for those who are
not familiar brain oscillations are
these neural oscillations that you can
actually measure using an EEG cap
because the human brain has so much
activity it will pass through this Co
and we can detect it by these feudal
electrodes so you generated these
oscillations these oscillations are
correlated with several human behaviors
and in diseases I think the classical
example is a seizures you can see the
graphic here that if there is a seizure
activity the EEG pattern or the shape of
these waves will dramatically change so
they are really important especially if
you want to compare this organoids with
the REO activity that happens in the
brain so we start looking for the neural
oscillations in these organoids and the
way we do that was by creating
population spiking from our raster plot
as well as by filtering the data from
the mutalisk array in creating what we
call local field potential which is
really the basis for these oscillations
to arrive in and when they do arrive on
the beginning by 8 8 to 10 weeks we've
we see no oscillations after that the
oscillations become clearer more complex
by 6 months and after that they become
quite irregular less battery but
pathological so this is a sign of
complexity you can visualize these
oscillations in different formats for
example I'm showing here population
like in the voltage these are the
formats of these wave the shape of these
waves over time as I mentioned in two
month the oscillations are not there by
formant you can see a small Peaks
appearing in six months there is no
questions that you have regular sila
tori activity these bring organoid and
by eight months what we see that those
oscillations become quite regular and we
see even what we call a rebound effect
of these oscillations where they seem to
start to overlap so we can quantify all
of that and this is the inter event
interval and just how frequent the the
peaks of these waves become and you can
see that increases over time by four
weeks it's really high 0.8 the maximum
would be one and if you quantify the
number of sub peaks on on these through
the five waves we see the expected
inverted u-shaped curve suggesting that
up to 25 weeks what we have is just an
increase in the frequency but after that
we see that the subjects start to
overlap because of that rebound effect
the only way for this complexity to
emerge is if we move from a simple
activity where neurons are connected to
each other moving to a more recurrent
connectivity where synapses are being
trying between different neurons and
finally reaching a complex activity that
are more flexible abundant and
recurrency recurrent connectivity among
these neurons so all of that is quite
exciting but can we actually compare
that to anything related to the human
brain and then I come back to that
question can we compare brain organized
to the human brain and so they are quite
differently structures but similar to
global gene expression I mean if you are
comparing the number of G's
Express yes we can do that it's not
perfect but we use the human development
as a guideline so we decided to do the
same thing let's use the activity of the
human brain as a guideline and then
compare exactly only the things that we
can compare in try to to to guess what
kind of age we have from this organoid
one thing that I must say that the adult
EEG that I show you before quite complex
it's full of neural oscillations there
is no space between them our organoid
oscillations is much more similar to a
preterm neonatal G and this is a pieces
of activity or times of transient
activities followed by a chi yes and
time doing them this is the part where
where the brain is just violence is
chiasm so when we are born we have lots
of these chiasm silent activity compared
to adults but as we age the distance
between these activities shorten over
time and that's how we acquire these
very complex EEG throughout life so we
decided that this would be some of the
features from the EEG that we could
perhaps compare with our organoids and
the way we decided to do that was by
training a machine on several EEG
features or parameters such as chiasm
time or frequency of the transient
activities and and to do that we were
able to collect EEG s from neonates
between 25 and 38 post conception weeks
these are EGS that doctors recorded when
the babies are premature just to make
sure that the brain activity is healthy
so we take advantage of this material
when we create a machine learning
algorithm and we teach non supervised
algorithm to find what is the exactly
age of the person they
it on the EEG in the machine does it
quite well much better than several
doctors that I know because the human
eye is not optimized to distinguish
between 25 and 26 weeks but the machine
can do it because there are qualitative
parameters that we use to train this
machine after the machine was trained we
feed them with the organoid data and the
multilateral array extracted data
relations and then we asked can the
machine matches the organoid features to
the eg features in predict the organoid
age in the data we have it is a mixed
feeling let's put this way so in this
graphic
you
well hello everyone this is Robert just
uh it looks like um Allison phone
accidentally disconnected so he's
actually calling back in and we'll be
able to resume in just a second I
apologize for any technical delays here
hello
by all you know yes yes all right some
something happen yeah all right control
one see I do all right
oh good all right so this is a what what
we have is a prediction and I'll give
you an example of how this prediction
was done this is when we measure the
inter event interval between the
different stages of the G or different
ages as I told you the interval becomes
Shorter's over time and the graphic here
represents the interval in our organize
and by 40 weeks
it matches this red line here that is
something similar to a healthy postnatal
human brain so organized by 40 weeks
matches some features found on postnatal
human brain which is very exciting to us
so now that we have an ability to
measure these oscillations we start
asking ourselves what are the basis of
these dynamics how the cortex can
generate per se these oscillations
without any input and output and that's
a very fundamental question and we
decided to address that using genetic
tools for example we use crispers to
knock down specific genes one of the top
targets that we have is mecp2 it is a
gene involved in neuro development if
you have mutations in pin CP to you Maya
so also have expressed diseases such as
Rhett syndrome schizophrenia or autism
so if you knock down any CP children
disorganized what we have is a
completely absence of these neural
oscillations over time they simply don't
appear suggesting that mecp2 is
essential for the appearance of these
network oscillations but how come
a Mississippi chicken can cause that so
we turn into single-cell analysis we
dissociate autogenic cells on the
controls and the knockout organ wide and
we run single cell Renee sake the first
thing that we observe is the
there is a significant decrease between
layer five and six neurons the knockout
organoids
have about sixty percent decrease in
those neurons if we zoom in what kind of
neurons are present in layer five and
six we actually find out that both CTP
xu+ cells and sattva qu+ cells are
reduced as a population in in the image
CP to look out organoids compared to
controls so this is just one example of
one of the factors that can actually be
responsible for the spontaneous
emergency of these neural oscillations
we are testing all their genes as well
we in and we are also testing for
mycological treatments different drugs
that might inhibit these bring
oscillations so from a basic science
perspective this is very interesting but
we also want to help families with
diseases so we look for potential
treatments for people with autism and
other neurological disorders so one of
the bottlenecks we have is our ability
to generate brain organizing large scale
so there are many people that are hoping
to create a more reproducible models
that could be used for this purpose so
my lab has a small contribution that we
recently published a paper where we can
generate these brain organ white
cortical organoid directly from I skin
biopsy so you just place a couple of
fibroblasts exactly coming from the skin
biopsy Nowell and using a specific
protocol in several weeks you can
already have a brain organoid that allow
us to do a high throughput so we can
gently could be inferior you generate as
many organoid from as many different
people as we want in poor conditions
such as idiopathic autism this is
something that we really want to to
explore other environmental factors that
may impact brain development on
different genetic background might also
benefit from this kind of technology so
we think that it needs further
development but is a proof of principle
that this can be done and we're quite
excited about that so I am finishing
here I'll highlight what you should take
from this presentation one is that a
spontaneous development of neural
networks on the Scourge coronoid they
resemble the brain biological programmed
trajectory so you don't need any kind of
external stimulus to really follow the
normal brain trajectory this was
something that was unclear if the human
brain would require some kind of
external stimulus but at least in vitro
it does not so we see Delta high gamma
phase amplitude that couples with the
synchronic synchronous events that we
see in the multilateral way electrode
array and this is a hallmark of court
inter inter regional cortical
communication the only way for us to
have that kind of rebound exact of the
soup eeks of the neural oscillations is
by having this kind of intra particle
communication I also told you that we
can use these these two to model
oscillations in a dish and we have been
looking for factors that can that are
essential for these oscillations mecp2 a
gene implicated in several
neurodevelopmental disorders is a strong
candidate and likely do that by reducing
the subtype of cortical neurons in layer
five and six and finally when we
attempted to compare the brain organoids
with features that are coming from a
human brain we use AED on post
conception different post conception
weeks brain and it seems like after 25
weeks we have a very nice
match it in vitro with the EEG features
in vivo so there are many people that
are involved in this work most of these
work was done by clever through GTO and
Priscilla neck rise two postdocs in the
lab all the neural solutions was done in
collaboration with the Wojtek lab the
single-cell analysis was in a
collaboration with the gene vo lab in
the libya lab as well I have a food
disclosure I have a company called T's
MOU that works on developing drugs for
autism using this technology my funding
agencies are mainly the NIH in inform
the California Institute for
regenerative and I also like to thank
all the families that support our
research with donations with tissue
materials and really to keep us
motivated to find better treatments for
all these patients so this is what I
have and I'll be happy to take any
comments and questions
great Thank You Alison for this very
informative presentation so with that we
will now begin the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now by
clicking on the ask a question drop box
located at the far left of your
presentation window type in your
questions the box that appears on screen
and click the send button and we will
try to address as many questions as as
we can in a time frame remaining so with
that Allison I'd like to get started
with the first question this one's um a
little bit more generic in nature and I
just was curious as you know a lot of
the 3d presentations I've seen over over
the last few years and and months um
there's really a common thing about
having to move to implant here that
you're organized ivana to really mature
them and to reach achieve that full
maturity what do you think is preventing
out sorry so but I in your model you've
been able to achieve some very good
responses what do you think is
preventing us from achieving this level
of maturation in vitro for many these
other models yeah I think we spend lots
of time on the protocol musician and
there are very simple things that you
can do to optimize your culture
conditions such as optimization of the
media or the timing of the sectors that
we use and I think is really a
combination of several factors that lead
to a protocol that can can reach that
level of activity in the past we thought
that we need to transplant these
organoids into a mouse brain or any
other animals to achieve this kind of
motivations but it turns out that we
don't but but even though I mean we see
that there is a plateau in the activity
by nine months and we think that this
stage is the maximum that the cells can
do per se and at this stage we very
likely need to receive some kind of
input and output and in and we are
working on ways to stimulate these
organoid hoping to have a better even
stronger maturation in vitro but we are
trying to stay away from the mouse
models because at the end of the day we
want to do some high-throughput these
studies
screen drugs or to model diseases in the
animal transplantation is really a
bottleneck for us great access we have a
couple of questions from the audience
first from the Seattle Children's
Research Institute are your neurons in
your organized myelinated they are not
we are on the stage a little before
where the myelination should happen we
could stimulate the glial progenitor
cells to turn into all ego progenitor
cells but we are not done that these
would require a second assimilation at
later stages so we are generating all
these level of activity without my
realization that's it
and another question what is the great
great advantage of using the any UN
antibody
the Nu these are an antibody that will
mark mature neurons so we are just using
to quantify the number of neurons that
are present in our cultures we do that
using single cell and they sick as well
but sometimes when you need
visualization of the protein level we
use the new end antibody
a couple of questions around how you
prepare or isolate the initial it sells
for it so I'll just read to and maybe
you can comment on both because it
closely related regarding your organs
from skin biopsies how do they compare
to other methods such as Lancaster and
Pascoe method out there in terms of
maturation and heterogeneity of the
neuronal population and a related
question they were curious on how you
dissociate your into single cells the
started audio pro yeah right so you guys
can have all details because we we place
a manuscript that's under review into by
archives all the details how we
dissociate the cells how you prepare the
cells can be found in bio archives
that's just search for my name and
you're going to see the protocols
available over there but briefly our
protocol is different from for example
Lancaster because we patent them we are
focusing on the cortex so we don't see
other types of neurons there is no
Spokane for cerebellar neurons in there
and as a consequence we gain more
reproducibility in more activity because
now all the resources for the neurons to
form synapses are restricted to the
subtype of neurons so it is it really
depends on your questions to use one
protocol versus the other so we are
really focusing on on cortical
development so that's why we are we are
choosing to patent this organoids
towards towards the cortex
ratchet excellent um a couple more
questions here then the cube is there a
need to incorporate vasculature into
these to improve or speed up the
mattress or in vitro or have you started
to look into that yeah so everything
that I told you is in the absence of any
English Elio vascularization and I think
that's why they reach a size of about
0.5 centimeter and they don't grow more
than that and I also mentioned that in
the center we start to see a little bit
of necrosis and that might be a result
of that so we and others are looking for
ways to Rusco rise the system but again
I mean we don't want to go into into an
animal model because that poses lots of
other questions so instead what we are
trying to do is to create artificial
raises that will penetrate this organoid
so we can pump blood or nutrients
throughout these vases and hoping that
they will survive longer they will help
them on speed up moderation and very
likely these organoids grow bigger
another question for the audience's how
well do these models correlate with
clinical treatment outcomes for existing
drugs how predictive are they yeah so
that's a great question and I don't have
the answer yet I can tell you that we
are running now one when big experiments
that should prove just how good these
are these models are the experiment is
the following we are running a clinical
trial for autism using a specific drug
here at UCSD and we're going to roll
about 30 kids and 30 controls all the
participants or the subject will have
their brain organoids generated in vitro
we're going to run the clinical trial in
vitro just with their brain organized
and we're going to use these easy
figures to show potential for translate
ability we should be able to inform the
the clinical trial on who is going to
respond who is not going to respond
based on the in vitro data if we have
100% match we can say that the model is
really good for that
so in but we we don't expect that we
expect that the model might be
informative but in certain aspects that
that would be like a very good scenario
for us
along those lines is a closely related
question what are some of your current
obstacle to transforming the technology
to screening workflows to initiate some
of that drug screening and toxicity
studies you're talking about yeah so
doing these protocols I think one of the
major obstacle is automation we go these
organoids and these two requires lots of
human hands to change media to automate
to keep an eye on them and these induces
lots of human errors so since these are
long protocols I told you that we can
keep them for years you can imagine the
number of frustrated people that have
their organoids after six months
contaminated in in this is like not only
a burden to the person when the
economics of the lab is also is also
factored so I think automation is
something critical and we start to have
some discussions with by engineers along
these lines I mean because it shouldn't
be that difficult to create systems that
will feed or take care of these organize
in a totally selfless way
right so another questionnaire have you
already tried to develop organoids using
2d cells and if yes which diseases at
which put and where are your primary
results are there differences that
dimension development or conclusions
yeah so we work with several
neurodevelopmental disorders there are
some where the phenotypes are more
dramatic than others I'll give you an
example we publish last year a paper in
Southie stem-cell describing the defect
on organoids generated from people with
icardi Gutierrez syndrome a very
dramatic neurological syndrome that
causes loss of neurons in that paper we
also describe the potential mechanisms
to explain the neurotoxicity and we were
able to repurpose a drug that was HIV
retroviral drugs that could inhibit the
laws of those neurons these drugs now
are in clinical trials so the mouse
model could not provide any insight into
the neurological aspects of this disease
so what is really the human model that
could do it and we have several other
diseases where we see phenotypes that
correlates better or or not-so-good to
the disease so the starting materials
most of the cells that we start in my
lab are coming from ischemia fibroblasts
or dinkle probe cells and we were able
to successfully isolate those primary
cells in reprogram and they do just as
fine compared to controls to generate
organoids
obviously for example in the case of
micarta Gutierrez we see a massive loss
of neurons at very early stages so you
can see that the organoids are
microcephalic from the beginning so they
don't achieve the same diameter as the
controls
thank you
around the range of the heterogeneity of
your models for example what is the
percentage organizers that passed you
see to be available for analysis yeah
so the QC is an important question we
have done some extensive quality control
disorganised to know what is a good
organoid what is a bad organoid and we
have compared organized generated from
different genetic backgrounds as well
and so there are some early QC steps
that you can you can use to detect if
you're organized we move forward into
the differentiation protocol or not cell
bath and the amount of the breeze in the
dish is some of the key things that we
keep an eye on it because we know when
the differentiation is not going well
these organoids will not develop there
will be stuck some time and in in the my
attach to each other so they so they
don't become like single individual
organoids they're just clump of cells so
these are some of the uses obviously
there are later uses once you have this
organizing hand i'm going to make sure
today they do have the different
cortical layers represented or the
activity level is what we expected we
for our our basal wine so there are
along the way there are several QCs that
you can apply
but thank you
there's a couple of comments centered
around the time it takes some of these
and and if there's any ability to
cryopreserve them or at some late stage
and then bring them back into the
screening campaign rate the question
yeah now that's absolutely great
questions we we keep an eye on that as
well so far we have not being able to
feed them in in pas and in continue with
a valuable organoid so once you start
the protocol you have to keep them alive
and that's why some people have them
going the lab for years the good news is
that once you have a batch of these
organized you don't make like one or two
you make hundreds if not thousands of
organizers at the same time a single
batch can give you enough to do like a
proteomic a gene expression single-cell
analysis in your letter physiology so
you don't have to generate a several to
get all the materials that you need so
this is the good the good news but the
bad news is really once you start you
have to do to keep to keep them we
cannot stop in the middle there is no
way the protocol that we can freeze it
down in recover later
we are testing some factors like real
tree of preserve ins that ow
it might work at our early stages but so
far no no success for us
postdocs and your grad students don't
have a much opportunity for vacation
sometimes it's a long commitment that's
interesting
and that's why the lab has to be very
social and they have to lie to each
other because they help they need to
help each other absolutely another
questions that around how could you
explain the different phenotype in AGS
organoids compared to the normal brain
development in patients
it matches really well because in in the
patients you can see already using
ultrasound that the brains of ajs
patients are is more suggesting these
massive neuronal death and that's
exactly what we see in the organ white
we see that needles just died in and we
think this is all because of these
expression of exogenous endogenous
retrovirus that causes these immune
activation of these organized and these
are very neurotoxic because it acts to
the interferon alpha so we actually show
that if you block interferon alpha these
neurons will survive and it can actually
rescue the disease the caveat here is
that you have to treat at very early
stages so there is no neuronal loss so
the treatments that we propose have to
start very early on the clinical trial I
mentioned was already like in a little
bit older kids so this is mostly for
toxicity and we don't expect a full
rescue what we expect I just is low down
the the progression of the disease
good and so with that I'm just going to
end with some to future-looking
questions for you
one in which is I'm just kind of curious
we have a lot of researchers online
today that are new to organize the 3d
model what what keeps you up at night
what are some of the major challenges
that you know are vital to be that you
need to overcome in the coming months or
years to really take your your neuronal
model to the next level yeah so this is
a great question I think the these early
stages of human development is such a
black box and we are so curious to know
what happens for example the fact that
we see that these oscillations are a
genetically programmed to appear and
doesn't require any put from outside
this is amazing I think this is
something that I was not expecting to
see to be honest I thought that I mean
ecosystem will never reach to that level
now that we know that we want to know
what causes that what are the genetic
information in these very early stages
that make these the cortical organized
to oscillate and in furthermore can we
use external input after their form to
really mature these brains to a level
that would be closer to for example one
year old or a two year old so that there
are the questions that we think we can
we can answer in the following 2 2 years
right and one final final question what
are you most excited about in the
organoid field what are you what are you
out there seeing that you're just super
excited about and will be this in the
future of organizing I think well there
is a couple of things but one thing that
we like to do in the lab is to use these
organoids to study human brain evolution
my lab has a long interest on the
question of what make us humans
from the perspective of evolution in
especially on on on higher cognitive
status that the human brain has compared
to other species so we are taking
advantage of these models to compare the
human brain development between humans
change
in other primates we have like the
entire zoo in the lab that we can
compare but our most exciting I think is
the ability to take advantage of enzymes
to added the DNA in insert ancestral
variant such as genes that are found in
the under thoughts but not in modern
humans to see what's the impact of those
genetic variants in modern humans so
that will give us like a hint of what
are the really genetic information that
was essential for our modern human
species to try to develop really sexy
technology to be able to be here in a
conference discussing this kind of data
we don't see the monkeys doing that we
don't see chimpanzees doing that it's
only modern humans so we are an outlier
among the primates and we want to know
well what happens at the genetic level
that creates a brain that's so unique in
the animal kingdom
thank you thank you again so much out
and we really appreciate your time today
and presenting on this model I'm very
excited to see your upcoming
publications and and your future work to
see how your model progresses so before
we go please note that today's webinar
will be available on demand for Ewing
through February for 2019 so the next
three months so thank you for joining us
and once again Thank You Allison for
your time today
wonderful presentation and I hope
everyone enjoys the rest of the today's
event thank you thank you so much Robert
hi